- I don't think I,
I still don't think
I am conservative
in the older
meaning of the word.
I'm definitely not, you know,
if you went and read some
particular political treatise
on conservatism, I'm gonna
disagree with quite a bit of it.
At the same time, I
find a lot of sympathy
for the arguments of
preserving something
that is worth preserving,
or conserving that.
So, yeah, I was
definitely not a radical,
definitely kind of
middle of the road,
average, everyday
Liberal left kind of guy.
And I was genuinely, like
you said, apprehensive,
is kind of an understatement,
to work with conservatives
in any significant regard.
Which has been really an
interesting experience,
because they're
exactly the opposite
of what the leftist propaganda
had told me they would be like.
(easy going digital music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is the founder of
New Discourses,
and the co-author
of "Cynical Theories,
How Activist Scholarship
Made Everything About Race,
Gender, and Identity."
James Lindsay, welcome
back to The Rubin Report.
- Hey, Dave. Good
to see you, man.
- It's good to see you.
You know, I didn't realize
until we booked you for today
that you've been on the show
a couple of times but
only in panel form.
You've never been
on as a solo entity.
- That's right.
- This is as good
as it gets, huh?
- Yeah. Well, here
I am to change that.
- Here you are.
So actually the first
time that I had you on
I had you on with our
friend Peter Boghossian
who everybody knows.
And when the show ended,
that was probably about
it's gotta be a good
three years already or so.
And when the show ended
I think you sort of
still thought you could
maybe modify some of this
stuff from within the left.
And I had kind of
shifted a little bit.
And when the cameras
went off, I said,
"Well, you know, James,
I sense that the conservatives
are gonna start liking you,
and you might want to go in
that direction a little bit,
because I think you're gonna
find fertile ground
for these ideas."
And I sense you were
kind of were like,
"Ah, I don't want to
do that just yet."
That's three years ago.
And man, it's been
a wild ride, huh?
- Yeah. It's been
quite the few years.
You were very largely
right about that analysis.
- This interview is over.
That's all I needed
to hear from you.
- There you go.
Dave Rubin was right.
- You were right. (laughs)
- You know, put it on your book.
- Yeah. So, all right.
I didn't need the
you were right.
But I think it does-
- No, really though.
- But it does illustrate
a certain something.
So before we even go
into that part of it
about sort of looking to
the right for new bridges.
When did you get
interested in all of this?
You seem to be the main guy
covering critical race theory,
you've been warning
about it forever.
You're taking the
heat for doing so.
When did this even
get on your radar?
- You know, it hit my radar,
it was very interesting.
I didn't know what
I was looking at,
obviously, seven
or eight years ago.
But I got involved
in a conversation
with a number of people.
The conversation
was about a topic
that nobody finds controversial,
whatsoever, Affirmative Action.
I was talking with a blue
collar friend of mine,
and he's talking
about his experience,
and the probably
well-founded suspicion
that his boss was
a diversity hire,
as opposed to somebody who
was actually qualified.
And in fact, he was
talking about how there
had been some incidents
where people have
been put physically at risk,
since he actually
works in a factory.
And there were a
number of other people.
And if memory serves,
a younger white woman
was present as well.
And she pointed out that,
there was no need
to tell this story,
because white men's
stories have been told.
And I kind of interjected,
and I said, "Now hold on.
I get where you're
coming from historically.
However, we're in a
new circumstance now.
And he's trying to tell
his actual experience
with what he's dealing with.
And so the idea that, you know
white working class
people are going
to be put underneath
the dominion
of possibly incompetent bosses
that were hired for
Affirmative Action,
or diversity reasons
is a new story.
And we should be telling that
story, and hearing this story
and seeing what there is to get
to the best possible result."
And it was just like ice.
"His story has
already been told."
And I was like, there's
something bad wrong
in that attitude.
That was the very first
kind of tip of the iceberg.
And then as you know,
we were involved
in the new Atheist
movement, Peter and I.
And our heroes, who
were friends previously,
I think with both of us who
largely don't like us anymore.
We're getting accused
of things like sexism,
and sometimes racism for charges
that didn't make any sense.
And that's where I started
to hear these words
systemic racism,
systemic sexism,
and to start to connect
that to certain stories,
aren't allowed to be told,
whereas other stories
have to be amplified,
or centered, or whatever.
And that's where
I really started
to get concerned and
nervous about this,
as early as 2000, probably
'14 at the latest.
And Peter and I started to
talk about it then really.
- So you and Pete
were ahead on this.
And then when did,
when were you like,
"Okay, well, I either want to
make a living dissecting this,
or I'm gonna write a book
about this, or I need to..."
You know, this isn't
a fun thing for anyone
to be involved in
at a certain level,
especially the way
you're involved in on it.
Because you're always
gonna be accused
of being the worst
things at all times.
When did you make that shift?
- Yeah, so Peter and I
decided to fatefully,
in early 2017, to
write a hoax paper
targeting gender studies,
as we've discussed.
And we wrote, "The Conceptual
Penis is a Social Construct."
That was its own little scandal.
But we spiked a football
I don't think we had
a right to spike.
We said, "We proved
gender studies is bogus."
I don't think we actually
had the evidence for that
given the poor quality of
the journal that accepted it.
And this created
some controversy.
So Peter and I, being Peter
and I, talked about it,
and we decided maybe we
should write more papers.
And so we recruited
Helen, fatefully,
and we set a set
out on writing the,
"Papers of the Grievance
Studies Affair."
And that's where by the
end of the year, 2017,
well into that
project, you know,
we're actually reading
their literature in detail.
We're not just trying to
pull jokes by that point.
We're getting feedback
from academic journals
saying these are the
things that you've written.
For example, like this
idea that you have to
kind of abuse students in the
name of progressive ideology,
under a progressive stack
with experiential reparations.
Is like the mistake they
told us that we made,
they said white fragility
is the right idea,
but the mistake you've made
is centering compassion.
You have to center discomfort.
Otherwise you might refocus on,
or recenter the needs
of the privileged.
And that's where I remember
getting that feedback,
and looking at
this and thinking,
that it's like pulling back a
tarp and finding a dead body.
Like something really
bad is happening here.
And as I've gone on
and I've read more
of their literature
over the years,
especially when I first
read a book called,
"Is Everyone Really Equal?"
In probably the middle,
early part of 2019,
which is written by Özlem
Sensoy and Robin DiAngelo.
It's an education
book written in 2012.
Now it's like, wow,
this isn't a dead body
under a tarp, it's a mass grave.
And at that point
it's like, okay
I have to basically dedicate
most of my time and
energy to exposing this.
It's not about making money,
in fact, I didn't make
any money for a long time.
My wife actually literally
supported us completely,
because she also saw
how important it was
for somebody to research
this and speak up about it
to say, "You know, something
is badly off the rails."
That these ideas exist
isn't itself a problem,
but that they're
institutionalizing
is a big problem,
that they're capturing
a political party
is a big problem.
And so I didn't make any money
for a very long time
actually working on this.
And I started to
research and I noticed
how often they use
the words, revolution.
Equity is not enough, this is in
a mathematics education paper.
Maybe equity isn't enough,
maybe what we needed
was a revolution.
And I thought
something really bad
is at the end of this rainbow.
And that's where
it's everything,
it's all I do now, is
something really bad
is at the end of this
rainbow, let's stop it.
- Yeah. That's why I think
your story is so interesting,
because it seems like you
just kept peeling the onion.
And it kept going
deeper, and deeper,
and getting in some
ways more perverse.
I mean, for the people
that didn't see the episode
that I did with you
and Pete in studio
where you talk about
the Sokal hoax.
I mean, in essence
what you're saying
is you wrote something
to be nonsensical,
and yet it wasn't even
nonsensical enough.
That's the really bizarre part
of the whole thing, right?
I mean, you couldn't,
you tried to make up
as nonsensical
thing as you could.
- Yeah, and that
was the thing we,
I mean that was one of the
things that clued us in
that there was a problem.
And it wasn't like finding
a dead body so much,
as it was, something's
bad off with academia,
is that every time
we'd write a paper
and we're all proud of
ourselves for how ridiculous,
or horrifying, or whatever
it happened to be,
we would find something
in the existing literature
that actually
already went further.
Like we wrote one paper arguing
that the real reason that men
participate in combat sports
like Brazilian jujitsu,
was because secretly the society
is repressing their
secret homosexual urges.
And so they have
to put those forth
in a reasonable, you know,
a male acceptable way.
So they have to
beat each other up.
And that's the only
way they can possibly
express their desire to hug on,
and wrestle with other
men and get that touch.
And we wrote this and
then when I found,
I'm looking for citations,
and I find this paper
that it's like, no,
all competitive sports.
- [Dave] Right.
- By a guy, and the guy's
name is Brian Pronger,
it's written in like
1999 or something.
And the title of the paper,
it's just, it's so absurd
was, "Out of My End Zone."
And it's basically talking
about how football teams
are all arranged around the
idea of basically having
the opportunity for men to
engage in socially acceptable-
- It sounds like the name
of a gay porn, frankly.
- It is!
(Dave laughs)
I mean, that made for a lot
of fun for us, of course.
We ended up titling my paper,
"Enter the Backdoor,"
for example,
about sex toys and all of this.
So, I mean, it opened up
a lot of doors for fun,
but it's like every
paper we tried to write
there was already something
that took it further.
We said this one sport, and
they said, no, all sports.
- And can you just
explained for the people
that didn't see that interview.
And again, we'll link
to it down below,
so people can really get an hour
on the entire paper
hoax that you guys did.
But can you just explain the
Mein Kampf piece of this thing?
Because I think that if people
aren't getting how
absurd this all was
that pretty much puts
the nail in the coffin.
- Yeah, especially in
light of the papers
that have come out recently,
where they're
comparing Whiteness
to a parasitical ideology
of dominion and whatever.
We have this idea that
it would be brilliant
to take some horrible
thing from the history
and just rewrite it
as intersectional
feminism or whatever.
And so it struck eventually
that what is kind of
this, the iconic, horrible
thing of history is Mein Kampf.
So let's look through
Hitler's autobiography,
and political manifesto and
see if we can find anything.
So I'm reading this book for
the first time in my life,
and it's shockingly
bad in all regards.
And you know, you read
chapters one through whatever,
and it's him whining
about his life.
And then he gets, you know,
"Well, here's all my enemies,"
and he's railing
on the Communists.
Eventually, chapter 11,
he's railing on the Jews.
And then chapter 12, I
turn the page, chapter 12
and it's like, we
need a movement.
You know, here's the
answer. We need a movement.
And I'm reading this chapter 12
and I'm like, wow,
that's very useful.
I can use this.
And so we took out the
word, our movement,
he didn't call it
Nazis at the time,
he called it our
movement in the book.
And we took out the
words, our movement,
and I just replaced it with
intersectional feminism,
literally just find and replace
on like Word or whatever.
And then it was like, okay,
now I read through it.
And I changed the sentences
so that they're not
complete nonsense,
that since we changed words.
And then it was like layers of
let's work in some research,
let's work in a little
bit of citations.
Let's pull from Bell Hooks,
let's pull from these
angry feminists.
And we came up with this
idea that there's a type
of feminism called
choice feminism,
that women enacting
their own free choices
is inherently feministic.
That is something
they actually hate.
The intersectionalists hate
this freedom of choice,
they're not big on
freedom of choice.
So that's not real feminism,
that's selling out solidarity.
So the whole thing became,
which is what Hitler was
asking for in that chapter.
'Cause he's got like, you know,
you have to get
rid of all of your,
you have to
subordinate your will,
no half measures,
blah, blah, blah,
and all for solidarity
to our movement.
So we just rewrote this thing
as intersectional feminism.
We thought there's no
way anybody's gonna
take rewritten,
Hitler as feminism.
And we sent it off to a journal,
a feminist theory journal,
and they peer reviewed
it, which shocked us.
And they sent back some
suggestions to improve it.
So we improved it
and we sent it off
to another journal because
they did not accept it,
and it was a feminist
social work journal,
and they did accept it.
They did accept a rewrite
of Hitler's solution
to his political
enemies in solidarity.
And we kept his bad mood,
we'll just call it a bad mood.
We kept that there.
- Yeah, bad mood, yeah.
- Yeah, a very bad mood.
We kept that grievance,
the anger in,
and wrote this railing
on women who believe
that making free choices
represents the goal of feminism.
And that they're selling out
their black sisters,
for example.
And it was accepted by
a social work journal,
which shocked us beyond
any level of being shocked.
At which point we knew,
something really bad
is going on here.
- Yeah, little did
you know where we'd be
just two years later,
because it all seems
to have burst forth
in a much more perverse way.
So to get to where we
started for a second,
when I said to you, "Oh,
you're gonna find common cause
with some of the Conservatives,
and it's gonna be a little
scary," and all that.
Can you just tell people,
because I think for people
that maybe only know
some ancillary little
thing about you,
well, I don't want to put
any words in your mouth,
but you were sort of, you
used to be just sort of
a nominal Liberal,
something like that?
- Yeah.
- You're not a political
radical in any way,
that's the irony.
- Yeah. I'm not.
In fact I still describe
myself on Twitter,
to many people's chagrin,
so it's a little troll going
on there too, as apolitical.
I don't actually find
politics that interesting.
I mean, I don't really care
what Joe Biden's up to.
I just don't find it,
oh, Democrats said this,
Republicans said, I don't
find it interesting.
So in that regard, I
really am apolitical.
I definitely, kind of
morally, and politically
like policy-wise
tilted to the left.
I'm largely not in like the
strict sense that you would see
from the Libertarian Party,
but I'm largely Libertarian.
I just want people to
do what they want to do,
leave people alone
for the most part,
and let's try to organize a
society that kind of works
around that as a
basic principle.
And so I've never really
been terribly radical.
I did lean left for sure.
And I was always a
little bit annoyed
with Conservatism overall.
I don't think I don't, I still
don't think I am Conservative
in the older
meaning of the word.
I'm definitely not, you know,
if you went and
read some particular
political treatise
on Conservatism,
I'm gonna disagree
with quite a bit of it.
At the same time, I
find a lot of sympathy
for the arguments of
preserving something
that is worth preserving,
or conserving that.
So yeah, I was
definitely not a radical,
definitely kind of
middle of the road,
average every day
Liberal left kind of guy.
I was genuinely, like
you said, apprehensive,
it's kind of an
understatement to work
with Conservatives in
any significant regard,
which has been really an
interesting experience,
because they're
exactly the opposite
of what the leftist propaganda
had told me they would
be like all the time.
- So let's do that, then.
Because flash forward
a couple of years,
and suddenly I believe
it was last December.
So December 2020, it was
the one speaking gig I did
in all of 2020 public
speaking, at least,
in front of a crowd,
probably same for you.
I bumped into you at
Turning Point USA.
This is obviously
Charlie Kirk's event.
It's, in essence a,
well, it's a Conservative
movement obviously,
but it's very linked
to well-known
Republicans and all that.
And that's where I was like,
"Ah, James, look at this,
look at you two,
three years later."
What have you found
as you've talked
about critical race theory,
as you've exposed this stuff,
what have you found each
side has sort of shown you?
- Well. (chuckles)
The left is either delusional
about what's going on, or lying.
There's no other way to put it.
They claim that people haven't,
the people that criticize
critical race theory,
for example, haven't read it.
- So that's the new thing,
as we're taping this today,
it's the number one trend
on Twitter right now.
And it's because people
like Joy Reid from MSNBC
are saying nobody, even
that criticizes CRT
even as any understanding
of what it is.
That seems to be the big move.
And even though
I'm seeing plenty
of people explain it
over and over again.
- Yeah. I don't think
they've read it.
Or if they have read it,
they've read it with kind
of these rose-colored glasses,
or without an understanding
of what the specialized
language actually means.
You read a word like democracy,
and you think it
means something,
"Oh, I know what
democracy means."
But if you don't understand
that in a
liberationist paradigm,
that it's not possible to have
a true democracy 'til
everybody is equal.
In other words, 'til
Communism is achieved.
It's a loaded word.
So they don't understand
that a lot of the words
in these things are loaded,
and they were
intentionally loaded.
The right however,
has been a bit
facile in its analysis
of critical race theory.
So it's been very helpful,
or very good for me
to be able to help them
understand it at a deeper level.
Because for them, they've
just been saying Socialism.
And while that's some
percentage truth,
20 something maybe percent,
I don't know how to
qualify those things,
it's not the whole story.
It's not the whole
story by any stretch.
They have, however, been
very receptive to trying
to understand more about it.
They've been very
curious about it.
They perceive that
something is wrong,
and don't have the vocabulary
to comprehend what that is.
Whereas, where I perceive
from people on the left is
that they don't want the
vocabulary to comprehend it.
It's almost like
they want their head,
if they're good,
decent, everyday
Liberals, not activists,
it's like they want
their head in the sand
to not comprehend
what's going on.
And so they constantly
get blindsided.
It's like I watch
some of these people
on Twitter that kind of,
you know, left country club,
very smart people, I call them.
It's like watching them step
on a rake over, and
over and over again.
It's like whacks
them in the face.
And they're like,
"Why are there these
rakes here?" Whack.
And they do it again.
And it whacks them in the face,
and like, "Everybody
should be nicer."
Whack, and it hits
them in the face again.
I think they should be-
- It's very Sideshow Bob.
- It is, it's really horrific.
So I feel like there's
this very deep desire
to learn more and
get it accurate
among most Conservatives.
Whereas others are
just kind of like,
"No, it's Socialism the end."
And then on the left,
there's just straight,
either delusional ignorance
or lying about it,
which is shocking.
- Has that changed your feelings
on what a Liberal is in a way?
Because to me it
exposed a fatal flaw
in Liberalism that I
did not want to see.
- It doesn't change for
me what a Liberal is
in the kind of classical,
philosophical Liberal sense.
What it changes for me
is people who identify
as the Liberal label have,
they're largely a country club.
They are largely
almost, at this point,
a cult that want to believe,
and have a social identity baked
into being left of center.
To where upholding
that social identity,
becomes much more
important than the truth.
So when you talk about
actual classical Liberalism
based on enlightenment
rationalism,
the truth is supposed
to be the North Star
for almost everything.
And so they have diverged,
and it literally is a
country club mentality,
or a social identity mentality
that has captured an enormous
swath of that population.
To the point where it's like
I've had conversations
with family members
and they say things like,
"Oh, well I really like
what that Ron DeSantis says,
but he's a Republican, so I
could never vote for him."
That's the entirety
of the analysis is
that they don't want
to look bad to their,
oh, we only ever vote
Democrat friends, or whatever.
That is disgusting.
That's something I never
would have identified with,
or respected even in somebody
even several years ago
when we were having
that conversation.
- Right, and it's anti-Liberal.
- It's anti-Liberal.
- It's anti-reason, right?
That's the point.
- Yeah.
- So as you then were
talking about this publicly,
then you start getting invited
to these Turning Point things,
and onto other, let's say,
Conservative leaning Shows.
And then you go on, I mean,
I've watched enough interviews
you talk about being an Atheist.
You talk about some of
the differences you have,
as you're unpacking
all the CRT stuff.
And it seems to
me, nobody cares,
which is very much
my experience.
- No, I actually end up having
really interesting conversations
with people who want
to learn more about
my perspective.
If I were trying
to be subversive,
which I have no real
interest in doing.
But it's much more effective
to be making friends
and coming in in good faith,
rather than just attacking,
because they actually want
to hear my perspective.
"Oh, I'll think about that,"
rather than, "Shut up, Libtard."
You know, it's been a
very different experience.
I've had nothing but a
very welcoming, friendly,
kind, interested
experience as I go along.
Because I'm trying to
offer them something
that is of value to
speaking vocabulary
into their experience.
They know something's wrong
and they don't know what.
And I've found nothing
but acceptance, actually.
I mean, a big red pill
experience for me.
I went to CPAC in 2020,
so obviously let me
get my devil horns out.
But I went to CPAC, and I
didn't know what to expect.
I didn't really want
to go, but I was in DC,
and I thought, let's
pop over for a day,
see what's going on.
I went one day, just
for the afternoon.
I didn't make a big deal of it.
I wasn't part of the conference.
Just wanted to walk
around and see.
And I expected I
was gonna walk it,
from leftist indoctrination,
I expected I was
gonna walk into like
the Whitest room in the world,
and all of these things
that they've said,
and it wasn't that.
And before that, I went to
this big Conservative
Christian conference,
and I expected again,
and it wasn't that.
I expected all of this kind of
like, hate against the Libs.
And you get a little
bit of that at CPAC,
but hate against this and
it's gonna be super White,
and it's gonna be anti-gay,
and it's gonna be this and that.
And it just wasn't,
it was just people
coming together,
getting to know one another.
And that the amount of
actual individualism
that each person
is, who they are,
bringing what they're
bringing to the table,
was the thing that
shown through the most.
And I was just shocked.
I mean, I went home
and I had to like,
just think about this.
I was like, this
doesn't make sense.
It doesn't match what I was told
about these evil Conservatives
these so-called
evil Conservatives.
Once you start realizing how
much you're being lied to,
bricks start falling out
of the wall real fast.
- Right, you start
seeing it everywhere.
You see a little bit of it,
and then there is no,
there's no middle ground.
Then you just kind of
see the lies, absolutely.
What about on the
religious side?
Because I know for a lot
of my Liberal friends,
those very smart people
as you call them,
whoever will still talk
to crazy guys like us.
They seem to have two things
that just fully stop
them from shifting
into what I would say is
a more cohesive reality.
One is abortion, and
the other is belief.
The abortion one, if you
want to go into it, we can.
But I think we don't have to
do that much political stuff.
But the belief one, I think
is really interesting.
Because you go into
these conferences,
and suddenly you have, you're
being invited by Christians,
by believers, and here they
have an Atheist telling them
about the thing
that's in essence,
destroying their church.
- And that's the reason, right?
There's this thing
destroying their church.
And I remember the first couple
of times I got invited to these.
I was hesitant, I didn't know
what I was gonna step into.
And what I found were
people who it was,
I don't want to put myself on
too high of a pedestal here,
but it was almost like
I was their doctor,
and they're saying,
"Our church has cancer.
What's happening? Can you tell
me what's happening here?"
And I sat down with some actual
fairly significant leaders
of faith in private settings,
both private and public settings
and just talked them
through, this is what it is.
And again, they're
very welcoming,
like, "We brought food for
you, come to our house.
My wife's making food.
We're gonna have a
dinner together."
And I thought this
is very interesting.
I'm of course going
to be respectful.
I'm not gonna like go into
a full, like Atheist tick,
and just start arguing with them
when they've invited me,
and we're not, that's
not the purpose.
So then I was like,
you know what?
They bring their
faith into everything.
So it's like, I'm
just gonna listen
to them about their faith.
I'm just going to talk to them.
I'm not gonna just pretend,
I'm gonna be who I am.
But I want to listen to them
and understand the world,
the way they
understand the world.
Like, "Okay,
articulate this for me.
What does faith see within
critical race theory?
What does it see about
the brotherhood of man?
What does it see
about the Mago Day?
Let's talk about these things."
And I just had some
very prominent people
of faith, both Catholic,
I think we're both friends
with Bishop Barron now,
and Protestant, just
lay it out for me.
Instead of arguing, when they
say some faith-based thing,
I was like, well, I'll listen.
What a radical concept, right?
I was like, "Well, this is,
I don't agree with all of the
presuppositions behind this,
but this is a way to
understand the world.
And as a matter of fact,
it's a good way to make sense
of a lot of things
in the world."
And so I feel like it's
actually deeply enriched
my understanding of people,
of each other, of humanity,
but also of the issues
that we're facing
in the world right now,
and what it takes
to stand up to them.
And what it takes to find
what what is it inside of you,
the moral fiber inside
of you that you have
to have to be able to resist
a ultimately Communist
demoralization?
- And has this changed
your feelings about belief
in any way for you personally?
- I'm much warmer to the
idea of people believing.
It hasn't changed my belief.
I very much like to
draw off of the lessons.
I love to sit and listen to
pastors, or priests speak
and tell the lessons that they
draw from their scripture,
or from the philosophy
around their scripture,
or from the history.
I think there's a lot of
depth and value there.
I'm very interested
in hearing it.
I still would be in the
great repository of wisdom,
but not literally true category.
But it's been very enriching
as another perspective,
another way for me to
look at the same questions
that we all kind of
grapple with in life.
It hasn't changed my
belief underlying,
I'm still an Atheist.
But it's been, I think,
enormously enriching
to how I think about the
problems of navigating life,
and society and interacting
with one another.
- So I think, but
correct me if I'm wrong,
you came up with the term
crypto-woke, related to these.
Was that yours originally?
- Yeah, as far as I know.
- Yeah, basically these
people that kind of get it,
but then they refuse
to do all the measures
to defend themselves against it.
Which is sort of what
you're describing
of the of the modern
Liberal I'd say.
Can you just unpack
that a little bit more?
Because if we can break
those guys, whoever's left,
that could be the key here.
- I think it is
the key, actually.
- To moving whatever's
left in the middle.
- Sure, and this is the thing,
I realized right
before the election,
I got invited to do a
long podcast episode
with Bret Weinstein and Jesse
Singal, and to talk about,
and we were gonna represent
three positions in the election.
Brett was going to vote neither
of the two major parties.
I had decided and declared
that I was going
to vote for Trump.
And Jesse, of course, was
going to vote for Biden.
And we were gonna hash
out our differences
in what he called
a unity campfire.
And in the process of listening
to Jesse defend his desire
to vote for Biden over
the course of a couple,
or three hours, I
realized that these people
that are rationalizing woke
ideology are a major problem.
Now, crypto-woke is a
pretty stinging term.
So I don't really want to
apply that as injudiciously
as sometimes the fray
on Twitter implies.
Crypto-woke would actually
imply that they are faking it.
I don't think, for example,
that Jesse is
faking his beliefs.
I think he's just kind of-
- Just to be clear
for people that don't,
he's a writer for New
York Magazine, or?
- Yeah, something in New
York Magazine, or New Yorker.
I get confused between
these things, frequently,
New York Magazine, I think.
He's got a book.
I've had dinner with him.
He's a genuinely nice
guy to spend time with,
as far as I can tell, but
he just doesn't get it.
And he's quite vicious
on social media.
- Well, I was gonna say,
he said some absolutely
horrible things about me.
I've never engaged
with him, other than
to call him out on the
things that he's called me.
I'm just putting that out there.
- No, fair enough.
- But anyway, you're having
this conversation with him.
- And I realized
these people who
are rationalizing this are,
what they called the useful
idiots back in Soviet times.
Are the people who
are, they, they, they,
what's the right word?
Whitewash is the
word I want to use.
They make this very
radical ideology,
seems safe and acceptable
to normal people
who read outlets like
New York Magazine,
or the New York Times
or the Atlantic.
Some do it probably willfully,
and they are
genuinely crypto-woke.
And then other people do
it just not realizing they,
I think the mentality is,
and I've heard this
from the many times is,
they can't really mean
what it actually says.
I can read to them a
piece, critical race theory
calls into question
the very foundations
of the Liberal order,
including equality theory,
legal reasoning,
enlightenment rationalism,
and the neutral principles
of constitutional law.
And they seize on, "Well, it
just calls it into question.
They can't really mean that
they want to undo those things.
They just call it
into question."
And then I say another quote,
that quote by the way is
in the first paragraph
of critical race theory
and introduction.
Another quote from that book
is critical race theorists
are highly suspicious
of another Liberal
mainstay, namely rights.
Highly suspicious of rights.
And they say, "Oh, they're
just highly suspicious of."
There's ways that
rights can go wrong.
By focusing on rights,
you actually can kind
of screw people over.
Like somebody could say
something really hurtful,
I could say something
really rude to you.
- [Dave] It's true.
- You could shoot back at
me, "Man, that was wrong.
Why'd you say that?"
And I can say, "Free
speech. I have a right."
And so they're gonna seize upon,
"Oh, well they're
not against rights.
They're just highly
suspicious of them."
And it's like, "Come on guys.
Look at the fruit in practice."
There's a speaking
into the faith,
what you learn from
listening to people of faith
and how they
conceptualize the world.
Look at the fruit that
the tree is bearing.
This is a bad tree. It
is bearing bad fruit.
And if you go and
read the texts,
yeah, you can you can
whitewash this down,
or maybe the word is redwash,
this down to where it's pretty
milk toast, or whatever.
But it's genuinely
quite radical.
And then they don't have
explanations for things
like maybe equity is not enough.
We need a revolution.
That's Rochelle Gutierrez.
I'm not making these
things up by the way.
So that I figured
was the problem.
So I started calling them out,
starting in October
of last year.
I turned my main
gun from the woke,
who I think are a huge problem,
and started aiming
at the people who
are largely making it seem
more socially
acceptable than it is
to a mass audience.
- They're laundering
it, that's it.
- Yeah, they're
laundering these ideas,
but in a different way.
They're not doing, what we
call ideal honoring before,
which is to get them into
socially acceptable publications
like academic journals.
But they're doing
a different duty.
They are literally
making them seem,
"No, no, no, there's this really
reasonable interpretation."
Where if you absolutely pretend
it couldn't happen here,
then that must be
what they really mean.
These people must be more
reasonable than they are.
And I feel like it's,
with the ones who are
unintentionally crypto-woke,
I feel as though they lack
the capacity to believe
that there are people out there
who genuinely think outside
of the broadly Liberal,
classical Liberal paradigm.
And who genuinely
want to subvert,
or overthrow that paradigm
for something different
that they control, that's
truly Totalitarian.
- Okay, so since the
number one trend right now
is critical race theory,
and the idea here is that
oh, the critics of it
can't even define it.
James, I think I asked you
to do this once before,
but now, I will give you
the perfect opportunity.
I've two minutes and 20
seconds on a Twitter video.
What is critical race theory?
- I don't need two minutes
and 20 seconds anymore.
(Dave laughs)
Critical race theory
is the belief that the
fundamental organizing principle
of society is racism,
namely systemic racism
as they call it.
Which is what you call the
cause, otherwise unknown,
unspecified cause, for
when there are differences
in outcomes where White
people come out ahead
of some people of
color sometimes.
And systemic racism
hides itself better,
so critical race theory believes
to add on to this definition.
The definition is,
racism is the organizing
principle of society.
The belief that that.
But to add onto
that they believe
that when you tackle racism,
it doesn't improve, you can't
actually get over racism.
It's very tricky
under a doctrine
called Interest Convergence,
that leads it to
hide itself better.
To put a better mask on,
to cover itself up better.
And so racism doesn't
get better over time,
it actually is permanent
and becomes worse,
because it's more
insidious, it's more hidden.
And critical race theory
is the tool they use
to uncover the hidden racism
that is present in all
features of society,
because it is the fundamental
organizing principle
of all social phenomena.
- I hate to guess that I know
the answer to this question,
but since Joy Reid is asking
people publicly on Twitter,
can any of the critical
race theory critics
come on my show?
Have you tried to get
onto any of these shows?
Have they invited you
on any of these shows?
- I have not tried.
- And would you go
on any of these shows?
- I would go, I've
certainly not been invited.
I don't know if you've
noticed on Twitter,
that people keep
saying, like Joy Reid,
I think I even used her
earlier, on Twitter.
They post, nobody blah,
blah, blah, can define it.
And then I just post a
GIF of a stealth bomber.
That's me, I'm the
stealth bomber.
They don't pay attention to me.
They try to pretend
I don't exist.
Maybe it's because they
don't know who I am,
and maybe it's
because they know good
and damn well I can do it.
- Well, not only you, but
also Karlyn Borysenko,
she immediately
responded to Joy Reid,
and said exactly what it was,
she laid it out beautifully.
Chris Ruffo responded.
I mean, it's not that nobody's,
I've had enough shows on this,
that it's not that
nobody is responding.
What about the other part of it,
where it is prescribing things
that we've all fundamentally
believed were good.
Like being on time,
and hard work,
and knowing empirical truths,
like two plus two equals four?
That suddenly those
things are thought of
through the critical race lens,
as White supremacist tools.
I mean, if that's what
a White supremacist is,
showing up to work on
time, working hard,
caring about truth, (laughs)
I guess I'm a White supremacist.
- Yeah, I know.
They've included
things like loyalty,
I mean like basically
every single virtue.
- Virtue, yeah.
- That upholds society.
Because they are
utterly convinced
that the society that
we currently occupy,
which is broadly we could say
a classically Liberal republic,
was founded by people who
are White supremacists.
And they founded it with,
this is a conspiracy
theory, by the way,
they founded it with the intent
to maintain White
supremacy forever.
And so everything
that they valued,
everything that Thomas
Jefferson valued,
everything that George
Washington valued,
everything that
Thomas Paine valued,
John Lock valued,
everything that
Isaac Newton valued.
And he's even kind of
pre-enlightenment in a sense.
They really hate Newton, though.
All of these people
were actually trying
to establish White supremacy
as the dominant orthodoxy
for the rest of time.
That's literally a
conspiracy theory.
I don't know what in the world.
The books, they have
a book, Charles Mills
has a book, 1997 or
something like this,
called, "The Racial Contract."
That says that all White
people are secretly involved
in a racial contract,
and we all assent to it.
Although, nobody ever
actually talks about it,
or tells anybody about it.
(Dave laughs)
That we're gonna
keep White people up,
and keep people of color,
especially Black people, down.
- Do you sometimes admire
it for sort of like
the conspiracy behind it?
How sort of it all
encompassing it came to people.
You know we played the clip,
I know you saw it, too.
We played the clip of
Marc Lamont Hill's show,
and Chris Ruffo was on.
And Marc Lamont Hill
lays out a question
that just on its
face, makes no sense.
He's saying to Ruffo,
"Well, tell me what you
think about being White,
why being White is so great."
And that's not
Ruffo's intention.
- Right.
- His intention
is not to be racist.
But it's like, even
in Ruffo's answer,
which was quite good,
you could see,
there was literally
no nugget of truth
that Lamont Hill
was gonna be willing to accept.
- (laughs) It's like a highly
evolved virus, frankly.
And in the the sense
of like kind of-
- That's why I keep
comparing it to "Alien."
It's "Alien," you've
got to admire it!
- Yeah, it's like
yeah, stepping back,
and looking at it
from that perspective,
it's like, wow, it's
really figured out,
in the virus metaphor,
which I use Liberally,
because they have
a paper called, "Women's
Studies as a Virus."
They published in
2016 where they say
that the ideal way to
think of themselves
is as a virus, for instance,
HIV, Ebola and SARS.
Those are the ones they name.
Or a virus that causes cancer,
'cause cancer represents
true transformational change,
so therefore cancer good.
We're cancer, that's
their argument.
If you look at it
from that though,
to see how it's exploited
the receptor sites
of Liberal society.
But also, even, like religion
and Conservative society.
It's gonna latch on
to that kindness,
that respect, that charity.
It's gonna force you to be kind.
But then when you say,
"Well, you need to
be kind in return,"
they say, "You're forcing me
to participate in your regime."
The way that it's
been so successful
at latching on to
those receptors,
like, "Oh, I want to
hear your argument,
give me your best argument,
let me hear you out."
And then the second you
turn around they say,
"Oh, well your argument is based
on trying to maintain
your privilege.
There's something, from
the virologist perspective,
perversely beautiful
to behold in this.
This is a matter of
great interest, I think,
for psychologists
to start sorting out
over the coming decades
if we survive this
as a civilization.
It's hard to respect in the
kind of direct sense, though,
because it's patently evil,
it's blatantly racist,
it's blatantly destructive.
It has nothing to build.
Look at, for example,
the brand equity of
Harvard University.
I just saw the article in
the Wall Street Journal
that said, I won't hire
Ivy-Leaguers anymore.
Which I predicted by the way,
in a conversation with
Yale-ys a few months ago.
I was like, "It's only
a matter of time."
I wouldn't hire an
Ivy-Leaguer right now.
- I wouldn't either.
- And I would hesitate
to hire a college grad.
And it's like,
that's the next step,
that's where it's going.
It burns through brand equity,
it burns through real
equity so quickly,
'cause it can't build,
it has nothing to build.
There's nothing to
respect in that.
- Do you think a guy
like Bernie Sanders,
who I don't know
what he truly thinks
about critical race theory.
I mean, he'll constantly
tell you America is racist,
and all of that kind of stuff.
I don't know what
he really thinks
in terms of that specifically.
But do you think he realizes
what he helped usher in?
Like the average Progressive.
I would put him at the sphere
of the radical movement.
Do you think he realized what
was gonna come behind him?
Or that it is going to
destroy him one day?
- I don't think so.
I don't think that they
have any realization
that they actually
played a significant role
in bringing in this thing.
Which has largely already
marginalized them.
I mean, with Bernie,
he's been co-opted.
He was certainly not an
identity politics guy in 2016,
and then all of a
sudden he's like
a raging identity politics
guy, like something changed.
A lot of my friends who
are big Bernie supporters,
were very much against
identity politics.
And then through
the years of Trump
they brainwashed these
people that Trump's a racist,
Trump's a sexist,
blah, blah, blah.
So if you don't
come on the board
with identity
politics, you probably
are somehow a Trumper.
And you sympathize with
Trump ideology, or whatever.
They were very
successful at this.
And so I don't think
they're able to accept
their own involvement
in what has occurred.
Because they see themselves
as having been against it.
And then some greater evil
I think came into the world,
Trump, of course, the
greatest evil of all,
all orange menacism
there have ever been.
And they have to, I seriously,
I think they cooked
their noodles, man.
I don't think that they're
seeing things straight,
because the orange man
bad is such a center,
it's like, not a black hole,
but like an orange hole.
(Dave laughs)
That just bends all the
light rays around it,
and they can't see straight.
- Right, right, right.
That's like "Interstellar."
You can't see on the other
side of it, kind of thing,
'cause it's sucking
the light through.
What should the
average person know?
For the average person
that doesn't want
to fight about this all day.
But what do you think the
average person can do?
Because that seems
to me is the answer.
And we're seeing more and
more of it, by the way.
Every day now,
there's a viral video
of a mother at a conference
fighting the teachers,
fighting the administrations,
"I don't want to teach
my children to be racist.
I don't want to
teach my children
that they're bad,
because they're White."
Or, I just saw one this morning
of a Black mother saying,
"I don't want to
teach my children
that they're damaged,
because they're Black."
All things that a sane
person would agree with.
What do you think can be
done for the average person,
or by the average person?
- The average person
has to realize
what I started to say very
vigorously last summer,
and I was of course,
resoundingly mocked for this.
This isn't going to blow over.
We're either going to
push it out of power,
or it's not going to get
out, it's going to continue.
There is no letting
it blow over.
It's not going to blow over.
So you have to decide what
you want to do with that.
Not everybody is going to
be the person who stands up,
and speaks at
their school board.
But you can be the person
who makes that person dinner.
Not everybody is
gonna be the face,
not everybody's
gonna take the risk.
But you can be the person
who offers moral support,
who creates that network.
But the most important thing
then for people to realize
is this is a lesson that I
learned watching people stand up
to absurd COVID policy,
is that courage begets courage,
and cowardice begets cowardice.
It's a two-sided street,
or two-sided coin.
So there's this video
that went around,
I don't know if I could find
it again easily on Twitter.
And I think it was in
Canada, but maybe it wasn't.
But it was a bakery, or
a shop, or something.
The health inspector
comes in, or whatever,
the COVID cops come in,
and they're hassling him.
And finally, this one guy says,
"You're trespassing,
you need to go."
And everybody was
kind of cowering.
And the second one guy spoke up,
the whole crowd starts yelling,
"You got to go, you got
to go, you got to go."
And they ended up leaving.
It's the most blatant
demonstration I've ever seen.
That nobody speaking up,
everybody kind of shied,
everybody's kind of
getting bullied around.
The second one person
spoke up, a crowd erupted.
And that's one other thing.
If you're afraid
to be the person
who's going to inspire the
courage that begets courage,
I jumped off a cliff, man,
you jumped off a cliff.
We didn't know where
we were gonna land.
Right now, if you
jump off the edge,
it's not a cliff, it's a stage,
and there are hands
ready to carry you.
- Yes.
- And people need
to understand that.
The groundswell against
critical race theory,
it's the biggest trend
on Twitter right now,
as we were saying a minute
ago at the time of the taping.
It huge, it is a hot issue.
It's 85%, 95% depending on
where you are, Red or Blue,
issue for most people in
most jurisdictions right now,
of get this crap
out of our schools.
You have every reason in
the world to be courageous.
And your courageous is
going to be infectious.
On the other hand,
if you're a coward,
other people see your cowardice,
and either somebody's gonna
step and be courageous
instead of you, and you
did nothing respectful.
Or it's just gonna encourage
more people to stay silent,
more people to keep
their head down,
more people to hope, "Oh,
maybe it'll blow over,
and I don't have
to take a risk."
But that's not what's
going to happen.
It's either gonna
get pushed out,
or it's going to kill us.
- Jump, it's all people can do.
So actually, speaking of
jumping, when you jump,
and then suddenly
you're out there,
and you're taking
what are thought of
as unpopular positions,
however, true as they may be.
You're gonna get mobbed.
And one of the interesting
things was a few months ago,
you were trying to
explain to people
that critical race
theory was going
to be incredibly destructive.
And perhaps the biggest threat
to Jews in modern times.
Or in our times now, let's
say since the Holocaust,
something like that.
- Yeah.
- You got then called
an anti-Semite for that.
And there's been a ton
of people calling you.
I've defended you,
I'm more than happy
to defend you always
on this stuff.
And these are the same people
who call everyone else a Nazi.
Can you explain a little
bit about how Jews
don't fit into that calculator?
And why you were
warning about this.
- I mean, there are multiple
reasons I was warning about it.
But I do think that
critical race theory poses
the greatest threat
to Jews in America
and throughout the West,
maybe the whole world, today.
Certainly, we're not talking
about 1930, whatever.
Certainly, not that.
But the greatest threat now,
and we see people getting
beat up, it posits the Jews.
And there's a book called,
"How Jews Became White Folks,"
by Karen Brodkin from the '90s,
'98 or something like this.
And she lays out
that Jewish people
were not considered White
when they came to America,
you know, largely following
the Holocaust, for example.
They were discriminated against,
they were ghetto-ized,
et cetera.
And then they worked
very diligently
to become recognized as White,
often throwing Black people,
and other people of
color under the bus.
Which is not
historically accurate.
They often tended
to be Progressive,
and integral in civil rights
movements in many regards.
And so they
positioned themselves,
and she actually
makes this argument,
not just as White, to gain
access to White privilege,
but as the setters of Whiteness.
The people who are the highest
level of White culture,
who get to be the
cultural, yeah.
The people who
create White culture,
and define White culture.
So they literally
become the people
at the very top
of White culture,
and then they hoard the
resources for themselves.
And this is a literal
recreation of anti-Semitism.
And the thing is, what
I was warning about,
is this is its own
serious danger.
Far left anti-Semitism
is on the rise,
it's going to continue
to be on the rise.
I said there's a
normal baseline,
which I apparently
got accused of that,
apparently as normalizing
it, they said.
But I was just trying
to express in a Tweet
that anti-Semitism
already exists,
now there's more coming
from the far left.
But I said, there's also more
coming from the far right.
Because many Progressive Jews
are actually touting
this ideology.
And then for me, who ties
into to its historical roots,
for example, in the Frankfurt
School of Critical Theory,
which is correct
to tie it to that.
Those guys were all Jews.
The so-called cultural
Marxism conspiracy theory,
that's a Wikipedia entry now,
there is now cultural
Marxism explained there.
There's just a
conspiracy theory.
Is that, oh, these
Frankfurt school Jews wanted
to overturn Western
Civilization.
And that's a conspiracy
theory, it's anti-Semitic.
So I said there are people,
as somebody who
criticizes that a lot,
people come to me all the
time and they're like,
"James, just admit that
is it actually Jews."
I'm like, "No, it's Communists."
And they're like, "Just
take the last step."
So all these actual anti-Semites
are always trying to
get me to go that far.
And I've had some very
scary conversations
with some far right characters.
Not Nazis, but kind
of mainstream dudes,
who are getting more
and more seduced.
And I said, "There's
going to be a rising,
or there is a rising
far right anti-Semitism
that's new from that
normal baseline.
And it's ident-
- And by the way,
by the way, the point
that you're making there
is also something
that Dennis Praeger
has been arguing for
years, and years and years.
That these people who traded
in all their beliefs as Jews
for Progressivism, Leftism,
Socialism, Communism,
everything else,
they're not doing it
in the name of Judaism,
they're doing it
in the name of that ideology.
- Exactly, and the problem is,
as reactionaries
often tend to be,
they're not real precise.
So they see a bunch of
Jews, they camp Communism,
and they're like, "Ah-ha,
Communism is Jewish,
just take the last step."
And I'm like, "Guys, this
is a disaster in the making.
This is a tidal wave of hate
for Jews from both sides,
from the fringes of both sides,
that's on the rise,
rapidly on the rise."
And I warned about this.
And then some important
blue check people,
immediately accused me of
blaming Jews for anti-Semitism,
which is one of these
third rail things,
that you're not
allowed to touch.
I'm going to continue to
point out this problem,
because we're headed
to a catastrophe.
- When we see what's happened
over the last couple months.
So okay, so there were
the attacks on the Jews
in New York, and LA,
and all over the place.
But then, what was
also preceding that,
was all of these attacks
that unfortunately
were done almost exclusively
by Black people on Asian people.
So it was very confusing for
the intersectional calculator,
and very confusing
for mainstream media.
So all of the messaging
out there was,
"Oh, we stand with our
Asian brothers and sisters."
Which I don't want anyone
to have any hate crimes
against them, of course.
But they could never really
say who was doing it.
And now, there's some
videos leaking out
where we are seeing Black
people attack Asian people.
And then there was video just
in the last little while,
where the guy said, "Well,
you're the oppressive class.
I can't be racist towards
you, you're Asian, I'm Black."
That is critical race theory,
that's literally in the docs
that you're referring to.
- Yeah, that's exactly right.
Asians, and Jews also,
when they're not
considered White directly,
Asians are often
considered White adjacent.
They're said to have taken
up the values of Whiteness,
and these hard work,
and punctuality,
and loyalty, and all of
these different things.
They've taken up these values.
And therefore, they're complicit
in the maintenance
of the oppressive
White supremacist system,
even though they're not.
So now they're seen not just as
people who are
upholding the system,
but also, traitors to the
solidarity of racial oppression
that the theory posits.
And so you add in
that to the fact that,
"Oh, this oppressive system
is screwing you over.
If you're Black, you
have no opportunity,
because the oppressors.
I don't know if they think
that Black people can't read,
they can, and they go and read.
And they say oh-
- Well, Joe Biden thinks
they can't open computers,
or something, I don't know.
- Joe, I don't
know, Joe Malarkey,
I said that on TV accidentally.
(Dave laughs)
(laughs) Whoops.
No, but they go look.
And they say, "Well,
all the opportunities
and education are being
stolen, because of Whiteness.
And they're excluding
Black people,
and they're stealing
it from Black people."
And they can go look
at the statistics
and see these
advanced high schools
are 70% Asian.
It's like, it's not that hard
to figure out who you're
gonna jealous and mad at.
And then when you
add in the fact
that you have
economically depressed,
and stress, and the
COVID, and the crime,
and everything else is rising,
and all these
stresses are rising,
mentally ill and criminal people
are being just let off
in this Democrat cities.
It's only a matter of time,
you're gonna start
seeing violence.
And the violence
is going to happen
along predictable pathways,
where there's scapegoating.
And so Whiteness,
Asian, you're having
your opportunity
stolen from you.
Well, who's stealing? Well,
the school's 70% Asian,
well, it's probably the
Chinese, let's get them.
It's not hard logic.
- Speaking of the
Chinese, do you think,
not the Chinese people, but
the government of China.
Do you think that it
is somehow complicit in
spreading this stuff
in the United States?
It seems to me
that if you wanted
to win a war against
the United States,
you're probably not
doing it with nukes,
and troops on the ground, right?
We're not gonna suffer
a ground invasion.
But that in essence, we will
just do it to ourselves,
and you won't need
one bullet fired.
Or perhaps, Russia,
or something else?
- Well, it's certainly the case
that the Chinese
understand the dynamics
of a cultural revolution,
that's undeniable.
But the direct answer to your
question is, it has to be yes.
I don't think it's
always been that way,
or even necessarily
for long been that way.
They used to make fun of
the biso, the White Left,
and then they stopped
making fun of them.
And then all of sudden
you see this summit,
this diplomatic
summit in Alaska.
And what are the Chinese hitting
our American diplomats with,
and they have no defenses to?
It's, "Oh, well, you guys
are systemically racist."
And what do you see
their propaganda accounts
on social media
constantly hammering?
'Oh, you guys are
systemically racist."
We're not gonna
listen to the West,
or to America, 'cause
there's no moral authority,
because of its systemic
racism problem.
Until they fix it.
Meanwhile, of
course, very famously
they have like commercials
where the Chinese
girl is washing
the Black guy Asian in the
washing machine with soap.
- [Dave] Right.
- It's like, they're
not exactly great
on that issue themselves.
So certainly,
they're aware of it,
certainly, they are fueling it,
certainly, they have been
throwing money at things
that have gone down this path.
And certainly, they
would understand
that it will weaken
America from within.
The strategy broadly speaking,
is what's known as top down,
bottom down, inside, outside.
So if they can
infiltrate on the inside,
and weaken something
from the inside,
outside pressure
can then crush it.
So that's that aspect of it.
And they would understand
political warfare
and these strategies
extremely well.
I mean, Sunza wrote
the book on this stuff
2,000 years ago, or something.
- Yeah, all right,
last question for you.
You've given me the,
okay, you got to jump,
and there's gonna be
some hands to catch you.
I mean, just talk
directly to the parent
that's watching this right now.
Or the 16-year old
kid who doesn't want
to believe he's evil because
of the color of his skin.
Or the teacher who is afraid
of saying what the truth.
I mean, this has
infiltrated everything,
the guy in HR, the
freaking plumber.
Feel free to talk
directly to them.
- I got some bad
news to start with,
and then we'll get a
little more encouraged.
You actually have to learn
a little bit about this.
You actually are
gonna have to go read
at least a couple of pages
of critical race theory
to defeat that
argument that we hear
from Joy Reid, or whatever.
That the people criticizing
it don't know what it is.
Luckily, if you start
with some of the basics,
it's not that hard.
You have to get the gist.
Now, the bad news is over.
You do have to become
educated and informed.
That said, you're
not racist, they are.
They don't have the
argument, you do.
The evidence is not on
their side, it's on yours.
So they don't have the evidence,
they don't have the argument,
they don't have the
moral high ground.
You do have all three.
You have the evidence,
if you go look
where they're implementing
these diversity programs,
companies and schools
are doing worse.
The evidence that
racism is on the rise.
We see these problems
arising in our cities
being justified along the
lines of these doctrines.
You have the evidence,
you have the argument.
It's not hard to see
through how their argument
is actually completely bogus,
that oh, we're gonna
overcome racism
by putting more social
significance into race,
and intentionally making the
White race a negative thing,
and implying this imposition
of racial identity
on everybody, in this kind of
very politically active way.
And turning everybody
into political activists,
instead of educated, informed,
active, interactive citizens.
And then you also have
the moral high ground.
If they are injecting
racism into everything,
if they are the people who
want to tear things down,
and they try to frame you
out as a White supremacist,
or a sympathizer,
or as a racist, or
whatever, it's not you.
It's actually them.
So you have the evidence,
you have the argument,
you have the moral high
ground, don't be afraid.
Get a little bit informed,
get together with
some of your friends,
your other parents
at the school.
Talk to your kids,
engage with them,
engage with them on these ideas,
ask them to talk about it.
And then show up.
Show up and cheer if
you don't want to talk.
Show up and find
out who is talking,
and bake them cookies,
something like that.
Get involved in some way,
start getting organized,
you can do it.
It's all on your side.
- James, you have truly been
an all star in this thing.
And if anyone wants
to support you,
or find out more
about your work,
or bake you some cookies,
or whatever else it might be,
they can go to
newdiscourses.locals.com
where you own all
your stuff, my friend.
- I do.
- I don't own it, you own.
It's absolutely crazy.
James, continued, good luck.
I look forward to seeing you
in real life one of these days.
- Yeah, thanks, Dave.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about academia,
instead of non-stop yelling,
check out our academia playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
check out our full
episode playlist,
they're all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe, and
click the notification bell.